Mình đang phát chín, hôm nay tự linh khẩn cấp của Linh Rộn Arrop và Tổ chức Hợp Tóc Hồi giáo OEC,
diễn ra tại Luua Cata đã ra tên Bộ Trung lên án Israen.
Móc bò việc bủ chỉ tài định cứu người pelestine và kêu gọi cập đồng của tệ hỗ trợ công quốc tài khết giả gà ra.
Linh Rộn Arrop và Tổ chức Hợp Tóc Hồi giáo cũng kêu gọi điên chỉ từ các thành viên lên hẩn Quốc của Israen.
Tên Bộ Trung nếu gió các Cô Già thành viên đã quyết định phối hợp nỗ lực nhằm nóng băng từ các thành viên lên hẩn Quốc của Israen.
Mình cạnh đó, các bên cũng kêu gọi cộng được của tệ tham gia hôm nhỉ bị tài thiết giả gà ra.
Dương kênh sẽ được tổ chức tại Thủ Đô Kai Rô của域 Cập sau khi đã được tổ thận nếu bắn tại Bộn lạnh Thổ này.
Tên Bộ Trung lên mác, Hôm Bình ở Trung Đông sẽ không thể đã được thông qua hành động gây hình và sự phết lợp đối với Vấn Đề pelestine.
Hôm Y Trên được tựa chung nhả cà ta đăng cây.
Ngày sau luật tăng thằng liều thang trong khu vực đặc biệt với việc Israen không cất nhằm hạ sát cái lịch đạo của Phong Trả hủy rõ Hamas.
Ngày tạy thủ Đô Đô Hà, hủy tổ chức.